doch wird präsentiert vom neuen toyota
rav 4 4 x 4 und hybrid die ideale
kombination für die schweiz noch drei
stunden bis sonnenaufgang in abu dhabi
es ist er neunter märz 2015
dieser tag könnte als einer der großen
in die geschichte der fliegerei eingehen
solar impuls das erste solarflugzeug
dass die welt umrunden soll geht heute
an den start
im cockpit abwechselnd die schweizer
pioniere bertrand piccard und andré
borschberg
[Musik]
die kollegen
herr baustein das ganz kurz wie geht es
ihm sehr gut sehr gut endlich sind wir
da für das erste leg und dass sie sehr
spannend ihnen sagen da so dass er gut
mit rassistischen special exciting
moment
unterwäsche und politik werden
[Musik]
es ist eine stafette ein team flug rund
um die welt
[Musik]
andré hier ist albert ich habe eine gute
nachricht für sie
ich gebe ihnen grünes licht für den
start von solar impuls danke und vor
allem viel sonne
allein mit der kraft der sonne fliegen
tag und nacht ein traum der nun
wirklichkeit werden sollen das flugzeug
fliegt legen osten der aufgehenden sonne
entgegen
für bert tropica geht ein traum in
erfüllung
und der mann mit den stahlblauen augen
zeigt dass auch seine nerven nicht immer
aus stahl sind stress ist letzten moment
es war nur eine elektrische probleme im
cockpit wir wüssten reparieren am
letzten moment aber jetzt das flugzeug
in der luft oder ist unterwegs nach
roman wenn er das geht gut mache ja
nicht fliegen nach india und wir gehen
um die welt
das flugzeug ist in diese richtung
gefahren
denn alles geht gut es kommt von dieser
richtung in fünf monaten
[Applaus]
[Musik]
es ist der beginn eines großen
abenteuers ein wichtiger tag für das
team für andre bertram und ich glaube es
ist die realisation eines lang gehegten
traumes
man kann sogar sagen eines kinder traums
studiert
solar impuls das erste bemannte
solarflugzeug der welt startet zu seiner
weltumrundung in weniger als 15 etappen
soll es den globus umfliegen allein mit
der kraft der sonne
angefangen hat alles 1999 in der schweiz
per twitter startet in château de
zusammen mit dem britischen piloten
brian james zur umrundung der welt im
heißluftballon sechs jahre entwicklung
und zahlreiche rückschläge liegen hinter
ihnen
nach 20 tagen schaffen sie die sensation
doch für picard ist es der beginn eines
noch größeren projekts nach der
weltumrundung im heißluftballon dachte
ich an die 20 bangen tage an unseren
treibstoffvorrat der zur neige ging weil
wir die hülle mit propangas heißen
mussten ich dachte daran wie wir uns
wehren 45.000 kilometern 20 tage lang
jede sekunde fragten werden wir es
schaffen wird das gas reichen
in einer solchen situation fühlt man
sich total hat endlich gefangen und
versklavt vom treibstoff da habe ich mir
gesagt jetzt muss sich die idee des
ewigen flugs ohne treibstoff wirklich
umsetzen hätte ich von anfang an gewusst
dass dieses projekt 150 millionen kosten
würde ich weiß nicht was passiert wäre
vielleicht hätten wir uns gesagt das ist
total verrückt das machen wir nicht
zunächst habe ich die unternehmen
angefragt die einen direkten bezug zu
solar impuls hatten im energiebereich in
der luftfahrt und so weiter die hielten
mich für völlig durchgeknallt aber sie
haben es mir sehr höflich zu verstehen
gegeben
bis er 2002 an die pforten der eth
lausanne klopft
damals hatte patrick aebischer seit
kurzem deren leitung übernommen
[Musik]
ich erinnere mich wie er eines tages in
dieses büro kam und sagte wir haben ein
projekt gefördert das möchten wir machen
es ist weiters verrückt aber ich glaube
dass die eth helfen könnte sie könnte
die machbarkeit dieses projekts prüfen
buchstäblich innerhalb eines tages haben
wir damals eine million frei gegeben und
uns gesagt wir führen die
machbarkeitsstudie durch so etwas macht
die eth lausanne
das war interessant für uns weil dies
der förderung der spitzentechnologie
diente der für die forschung zuständige
vizepräsident der eth lausanne
stefan casillas übernimmt die
projektleitung datum war also in einem
unserer großen hörsäle in lausanne
alle setzten sie wussten nicht weshalb
sie eingeladen waren
und dann erzählt er ihnen von seinen
plänen alle waren sofort begeistert
plötzlich sagte ich zu ihm aber beton
ist ein sicherheitssystem vorhanden
falls es ihr flugzeug problem gibt
daraufhin herrschte große stille im saal
weil sich plötzlich alle bewusst wurden
dass sie da oben beträchtliche risiken
eingehen würden
nach einigen sekunden der stille
antwortete mir wertung aber klar stefan
es nennt sich falsch
[Musik]
die eth lausanne betraut mit der leitung
der machbarkeitsstudie andré boschberg
wer sich mit fallschirmen und flugzeugen
gut auskennt der pilotlinie und
unternehmer teil speakers träume
die idee fand ich absolut genial
für mich bedeutete aus die welt zu
betreten von der ich seit meiner
frühesten kindheit geträumt hatte die
welt der luftfahrt die welt der
innovation die welt die entdeckung
letztlich konnte ich dank der begegnung
mit der traum einen schritt in diese
richtung machen findet industriepartner
und überzeugt sie sich ins abenteuer
solar impuls zu stürzen
alle unternehmen wie solar impuls
unterstützen stammen aus anderen
bereichen aus anderen welten aus der
chemie der uhrenindustrie dem
versicherungswesen dem lift bau der
schwerindustrie leute die noch nie mit
flugzeugen gearbeitet haben noch nie
vikar gelingt es neben großunternehmen
weitere förderer für das projekt zu
gewinnen
fürst albert von monaco dessen
urgroßvater ein entdecker war bietet
ihnen einen standort für das
kontrollzentrum an monaco
andré borschberg stellt ein team
zusammen das ziel ein flugzeug zu
konstruieren das noch nie zuvor von
jemandem gebaut worden war
dann hat andere realisiert dass ihm eine
schlüsselfigur fehlt also ein jemand der
flugzeug konstruktion flugzeug
konzeption und design kennt er hat mich
angerufen und gesagt du da gibt es da
ein geheimes projekt kann dir den namen
sagen es geht um bertrand piccard und
ein flug projekt hättest du interesse
mal nach lausanne zu kommen für ein
meeting und dann habe ich gesagt ja ich
überlegte mir dass man dann habe ich mit
meiner frau darüber diskutieren sie hat
gesagt ja macht also geht doch mal
mindestens hin zu schauen was das ist
das könnte interessant sein und das war
fliegerei du machst sehr viel anderes
jetzt um geld zu verdienen geht auch hin
2003 gibt es also noch nicht einmal ein
konzept für ein solarflugzeug alles
musste erst erfunden werden
das französische ingenieur
beratungsunternehmen alltron beschließt
seinen brillantesten mathematiker zu den
verrückten schweizern zu schicken
die davon träumen ein von der sonne
angetriebenen flugzeug zu bauen
[Musik]
ich komme in der eth lausanne anklopfen
die bürotür von andré die tür öffnet
sich
ich sehe drei vor einem kleinen tisch
damals gab es noch nicht viele möbel und
wir diskutieren
er nimmt ein blatt papier papier und
beginnt mir das zukünftige flugzeug
aufzuzeichnen
wie ihr es sich damals vorstellen er
zeichnet die solarzellen auf den flügeln
die eine sehr sehr große spannweiten
dann drehte er das platzieren sagte das
ist es dann habe ich zunächst einmal
leer geschluckt und gedacht er glaubt
tatsächlich dass ich flugzeuge entwerfen
kann
ich habe dann sofort alles klar gestellt
und ihm gesagt dass ich keine flugzeuge
entwerfen können dass ich mich in meinem
job mit gleichungen befasse
dass sich mathematiker sein dass sich
komplexe systeme in gleichungen
darstelle sie zum leben erweckt sie
entwerfen die umsätze und probleme was
genau das ist was pyka braucht
jedes problem muss in eine mathematische
formel umgesetzt werden
dann findet man die lösung und kann sie
aufs papier bringen
die vorstudie die eth lausanne hatte
ergeben dass die maschine nahezu ein
ding der unmöglichkeit war
und alle fragten sich ob sie sich dies
oder jenseits der machbarkeits grenzen
wie siehts weg
ich glaube wir hatten alle den eindruck
aus dem nichts etwas zu erschaffen das
eine kleine revolution darstellen würde
[Musik]
sobald wir die machbarkeitsstudie fertig
hatten die uns den eindruck vermittelte
dass es möglich ist kontaktierten wir
mehrere flugzeughersteller die uns
umgehend mit halten dass dieses projekt
ihrer meinung nach nicht umsetzbar sei
interessanterweise hat mich dass er
stimuliert
es hat mich wirklich motiviert einen weg
zu finden um es zu schaffen
ich habe mich schließlich außerhalb der
welt der luftfahrt umgesehen
andere partner anderer technologien auch
andere personen gesucht um dieses
projekt zu realisieren
wir haben beispielsweise mit einem
unternehmen zusammengearbeitet das bis
anhin nur schiffe gebaut hatte und
keinerlei erfahrung im flugzeugbau hatte
wir sind von einem leeren blatt
ausgegangen etwa so zeichne mir ein
elektroflugzeug dass die welt umfliegen
kann
es gab viele rückschläge viele probleme
jedes mal haben wir uns kurzfristige
ziele gesetzt wir uns schritt für
schritt zur weltumrundung geführt habe
schritt für schritt jahrelang endlich im
winter 2006 ist es soweit der prototyp
der solar impuls wird aus den plänen zum
leben erweckt solar impuls 1 hat nur 40
ps und die aerodynamik macht probleme
auf der flugpiste in dübendorf darf der
flieger deshalb noch nicht in die luft
er rollt erst im laufschritt tempo
[Musik]
es wird wie eine große hängegleiter
fliegen aber mit steuern von ein
flugzeug so es ist sehr paradox aber
bevor wir wissen wie es fliegt wir
müssen wissen wir müssen wissen wir holz
zwei jahre später stellen piccard und
borschberg den prototyp solar impuls 1
den medien vor
ein flugzeug mit einer spannweite wie
ein airbus a340 und dem gewicht eines
autos
[Musik]
wenn diese flugzeuge gerne ohne
treibstoff da gute nacht fliegen nach er
kann niemand mehr sagen das ist
unmöglich erneuerbarer energien zu
benützen
solar impuls 1 fliegt und geht in die
testphase und auf werbetour
jetzt gilt es mängel auszumerzen und
jedes noch so kleine detail zu
optimieren überall erregt das fragile
fluggerät mit den weiten flügeln große
aufmerksamkeit
2013 durchquerte prototyp sogar die
ganzen usa
doch ozean überquert er noch nicht
es ist riesig und sehr leicht reagiert
also sehr empfindlich auf jegliche
turbulenzen
es verursacht viele probleme am boden
wenn zum beispiel die
windgeschwindigkeit am boden mehr als 10
15 knoten beträgt bei einer leichten
brise also gibt es von alleine ab wegen
seiner geringen geschwindigkeit von rund
50 stundenkilometern beim anflug stellt
sich das flugzeug bei seitenwind schnell
quer und bricht aus bei einem seitenwind
von fünf knoten dh neun
stundenkilometern beträgt der abweichung
winkel zur piste bereits 30 grad
[Musik]
es vereint zwei persönlichkeiten bei
ruhigen verhältnissen ist es sehr
angenehm
man kann es mit den fingern steuern es
ist sehr fein präzise es ist wirklich
eine außergewöhnliche beziehung bei
turbulenzen benötigt man viel kraft man
muss sehr aufmerksam und konzentriert
sein
solche situationen versucht man zwar zu
vermeiden
von zeit zu zeit treten sie jedoch
zwangsläufig trotzdem ein
[Musik]
es ist kein normales flugzeugen es ist
ein riesiges segelflugzeug mit vier
leicht motoren das jedoch so leicht und
so sensibel ist dass es bei mehr als
vier knoten seitenwind und mehr als
sieben oder zwölf knoten gegenwind kippt
und die nase beim starten oder landen
den boden berührt stellen sie sich vor
es herrscht gegenwind von 50
stundenkilometern da bleibt das flugzeug
stehen und bewegt sich nicht mehr oder
es fliegt rückwärts als sie in der nähe
des towers in dulles warteten konnten
wir über funk die gespräche mit den
tower mithören
wir hätten dann den ausruf eines der
fluglotsen als er sah dass ich das
flugzeug nicht bewegte what the [ __ ]
er war so erstaunt so etwas hat er noch
nie gesehen
[Musik]
potter verwies gott tatsächlich
das flugzeug scheint am himmel zu stehen
so langsam fliegt es 45 bis 70
stundenkilometer sind im vergleich zu
passagierflugzeugen schritttempo
[Musik]
wenn ein normales linienflugzeug eine
normale kurve fliegt neid es sich um 30
grad
bei solcher impuls hingegen leuchten bei
einer neigung von lediglich 5 grad im
cockpit rote lampen auf um den piloten
zu warnen und die manschetten an seinen
armen beginnen zu vibrieren
wenn ein neigungswinkel von 15 grad
überschritten ist weiß der pilot dass er
das flugzeug nicht mehr auffangen kann
dann muss er von sich aus entscheiden
die maschine zu verlassen
auch bei der landung ist bei solar
impuls alles anders als bei den anderen
das flugzeug hat nur ein fahrwerk in der
mitte und keine räder die die flügel
stabilisieren wenn sich die solar impuls
also der lande bahn nähert und aufsetzt
müssen helfer mit fahrrädern die
halterungen an den flügeln packen und
die flügel abstützen sonst kippt das
flugzeug
[Musik]
für die fluglotsen ist ein flugzeug das
mit 60 stundenkilometern auf den
normalen flug straßenverkehr tvi ein
fußgänger auf einer autobahn
[Musik]
man muss sich vorstellen mit 45 oder 50
stundenkilometern sind wie eine schnecke
oder sogar noch langsamer inmitten von
flugzeugen die mit 800 oder 900
stundenkilometern unterwegs
alle diese kleinen blauen punkte sind
flugzeuge
das flugzeug ist nun gestartet steigt
zunächst bis auf 4000 meter später auf
8.000 meter großen flugzeuge die hier
vorbei fliegen und sich schnell bewegen
sind näher bei unseren flugzeugen jene
flugzeuge die weiter weg sind sind
kleiner und bewegen sich langsam
sie sehen auch die flugzeuge die sich im
sinkt oder steigt flug befinden
hier haben sie beispielsweise nizza und
die anflüge auf mütze und die starts von
nizza aus
das hier ist die mittelmeerküste wir
befinden uns über spanien
sie sehen hier die flugzeuge welche die
balearen anfliegen
hier sehen sie die flugzeuge die in
barcelona landen oder starten
das sieht man sehr schön hier demnächst
werden sie viele flugzeuge sehen die
sich im sinne der steigflug befinden
was ist madrid einer der größten
flughäfen europas wir befinden uns
inmitten dieses verkehrs
solar impuls kreuz nicht nur den weg
hunderter viel schnellere flugzeuge
sondern muss wegen turbulenzen auch
ständig aufsteigen und anschließend
wieder absenken wie ein jojo
jeden tag steigen wir auf die höhe des
everest und sinken dann wieder ab auf
meereshöhe und das gleiche am nächsten
tag zu wiederholen
auch das war eine herausforderung von
der wir nicht wussten ob ihr gewachsen
sein würden wir haben mit amerikanischen
flieger herzen gesprochen
sie rieten uns von einem solchen flut
profil ab weil sie nicht wussten welche
auswirkungen dies auf den menschlichen
körper und insbesondere auf das gehirn
haben würde
wenn man sich am ende des tages mit
geladenen batterien auf 8.500 m befindet
nutzt man diese höhe um während rund
vier stunden sozusagen zu gleiten
am ende des tages und zu beginn der
nacht gleitet man halt so um eine
bestimmte distanz zurückzulegen ohne
dabei energie zu verbrauchen
wenn man schaut wie viel energie zur
verfügung steht nehmen wir die um die
mittagszeit auf einem quadratmeter
verfügbare energiemenge und berechnen
was die sonne her gibt nicht die
kollektoren so ergibt die sonne 1000
watt so viel verbraucht ein haartrockner
mit einem quadratmeter kann man also
einen haartrockner antreiben
auf dem ersten flugzeug standen uns 200
quadratmeter zur verfügung die sonne
lieferte uns somit die leistung von 200
haartrocknern
wenn man mit solar impuls fliegt ist
dieser gedanke absolut faszinierend je
weiter man fliegt desto mehr energie hat
man zur verfügung man braucht nicht zu
landen
man fliegt dank der sonne man schaut zur
sonne und nicht auf die tankanzeige und
sagt sich sie lässt mich fliegen
[Musik]
natürlich mussten wir auch eine
möglichkeit finden damit wir uns
ausruhen konnten
ich stellte mir vor dass 20 minuten die
optimale zeit dauer sind zwischen dem
was der mensch braucht um sich zu
erholen und der maximalen dauer während
ich das flugzeug praktisch
unbeaufsichtigt lassen konnte in den
ferien habe ich also geübt 6 7 und 8 x
pro 24 stunden während 20 minuten zu
schlafen
das war eine interessante erfahrung zu
entdecken wie ich funktionierte mein
rhythmus und die konzentration aufrecht
erhalten konnte
das erste mal als ich zu schlafen
versuchte war es nach draußen sah man
nichts ich war also von den instrumenten
abhängig ich entfernte mich von den
armaturen
das war schon etwas seltsam den sitz
habe ich in die horizontale stellung
gebracht ich habe mich hingelegt wie
somit vom cockpit entfernt und die augen
geschlossen
ich hörte dann alle geräusche des
flugzeugs das ist wie wenn du dich
nachts in einem dschungel hinlegt und
die augen schließt gar stellst du dir
vor wie sich ein löwe an pirscht um dich
zu verschlingen sich eine schlange an
schleicht um dich zu beißen und einen
skorpion befindet sich bereits auf einem
arm und nicht zustechen
genau dieses gefühl hatte ich anstatt
einzuschlafen waren meine sinne und vor
allem ein gehör hellwach ich begann das
geräusch der motoren und der struktur zu
analysieren
jedes kleinste geräusch das ich hörte
anstatt zu schlafen war ich hellwach
winter 2014 die testphase ist
abgeschlossen
in einem hangar in barrieren im kanton
freiburg wird die zweite version der
solar impuls die den globus umrunden
soll das erste mal zusammengesetzt die
mission einmal um die welt ohne
treibstoff ist zum greifen nah ein
kindertraum von picard breitet seine
flügel aus und wieder zeigt wie ein
glückliches kind sein neues spielzeug
sein cockpit das cockpit der solar
impuls 2 die nahrungsmittel ist in diese
schachtel sind da sie können hier und
sie haben die toiletten da unten
sie haben wasserreserven und wenn sie
wollen schlafen sie können so machen ist
das bequem ist bequemer es ist bequem so
lange dass der autopilot läuft wenn es
läuft nicht denn sie müssen manuell
fliegen und sie können nicht mehr
schlafen so wir haben sehr sehr viel
aufmerksamkeit gemacht für autopilot die
ingenieure müssen nicht nur über der
technik des autopiloten brüten auch die
fragile konstruktion und die aerodynamik
machen weiter probleme
so wie vor 100 jahren
die solar impuls gleicht den grashüpfern
der brüder wright zerbrechliche
konstruktionen aus holz streben sie
hüpfen stottern zögern bocken und
erheben sie schließlich in den himmel
erst einige meter dann immer weiter
und dann
eines tages
sollen sie die weltmeere überqueren mit
passagieren und ohne treibstoff
[Musik]
ich würde verrückt ja zu antworten ich
wäre dumm nein zu antworten weil er
heute natürlich gibt es noch nicht die
technologie und passagiere zu
transportieren
aber auch wenn die reit gebrüder haben
ihre erste flügel gemacht es war auch
kein technologie um die passagiere zu
transportieren
wir zeigen dass wir können etwas
unmöglich mit solarenergie machen können
und das ist ein flugzeuge der flieg tage
und nacht ohne treibstoff für ein
immerwährender flug und das ist etwas
das niemand hat gemacht mit einem schief
sie kundenstoppern mit einem wagen
stoppen könne nicht stoppen wenn sie
statt stoppen sie fallen die beiden
piloten werden tagelang und nächte lang
in dem kleinen cockpit sitzt nicht mehr
als vier quadratmeter stehen ihnen zur
verfügung
andré borschberg redet sich die enge
schön
auch für den rücken kann man einfache
positionen nehmen das war nicht den
rücken den jugendlichen da viertel
verkleinert und die spannungen auch weg
weg weg nehmen kann
man kann auch für die beine hoch nehmen
dass die not auch in unterfeld sowas
könnte es gibt viele möglichkeiten wo
wir denn diese lang oder mit diese lange
flugdauer und zu anpassen können
ein paar monate später die solar impuls
2 ist fertig startklar für das abenteuer
um die erde
der zweite wichtige schritt in dieser
ersten projektphase war meine begegnung
mit wir saßen an einem kleinen tisch in
einem wirklich kleinen raum
das gespräch beginnt und ich erinnere
mich wie beton plötzlich auf steht und
uns das hauptziel des projekt in
erinnerung ruft die botschaft das war
wirklich ein großer moment als wir ihn
vom projekt sprechen hörten von der
symbolkraft mit einem vibrator in der
stimme regen hörten vom abenteuer das
wir erleben würden
mit diesen strahlen auf dem gesicht da
waren glaube ich alle fasziniert
du musst dir festnehmen
[Musik]
ich hätte nie gedacht dass solar impuls
100 personen umfassen würde ein solches
abenteuer mit einer derartigen
organisation werden würde persönlich als
paar haben wir sehr viel investiert auch
als familie
wir alle sind daran gewachsen wirklich
aber wir haben viel hinein gesteckt
hätte er uns vorgeschlagen mit ihm auf
den mars zu fliegen wir werden ihm alle
gefolgt alle wären ihm gefolgt 112 tage
sind seit dem start in abu dhabi
vergangen die solar impuls hat indien
thailand und china überflogen und steckt
nun in japan fest seit wochen wartet
borschberg in nagoya auf ein
wetterfenster dann der 28 juni 2015
jetzt ist das wetterfenster da früh am
morgen geht die solar impuls an den
start
zum ersten mal in der geschichte der
luftfahrt wird ein flugzeug über 7000
kilometer nonstop ohne einen tropfen
fossilen treibstoff zurücklegen und
dabei den pazifik überquert
die ingenieure meteorologen und
fluglotsen nehmen im kontrollzentrum in
monte carlo die letzten vorbereitungen
für den start des flugzeugs vor
es ist wie der staat zu einer weltraum
mission
andré wir alle unterstützen die ich von
ganzem herzen wir wünschen dir nur das
beste
einen tollen flug ich wollte eigentlich
sachlich bleiben aber wie du dir
vorstellen kannst bin ich zutiefst
bewegt fürst albert sitzt neben mir
er wird den offiziellen start befehl
erteilt wir wünschen dir viel glück für
diese fantastischen der querung des
pazifiks kannst nun mit dem start
prozedere beginnen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hannover wenn man zur überquerung eines
lehrers an setzt kommt irgendwann der
zeitpunkt wo man zum letzten mal zur
basis zurückkehren kann
danach gibt es kein zurück mehr ein
entweder zu starker wind herrscht oder
das wetter ist nicht zulässt es gibt
immer einen grund weshalb danach eine
umkehr ausgeschlossen diesen zeitpunkt
haben die ingenieure beim flug auf zwölf
stunden nach dem start festgelegt bevor
borschberg diesen berühmten point of no
return erreicht muss er zwingend noch
einige tests durchführen
die resultate sind niederschmetternd und
die konsequenzen bringen das team
borschberg picard auf der einen seite
und die ingenieure auf der anderen seite
an den rand einer zerreißprobe
unser ziel war es zu prüfen ob sich das
flugzeug gut verhielt ob das
wetterfenster weiterhin günstig war
damit wir am point of no return sagen
konnten ob andre ist in der luft alles
läuft gut fliegen wir weiter in
wirklichkeit war es jedoch die hölle im
kontrollzentrum stellten wir nämlich
fest dass eines der systeme nicht
funktionierte das den autopiloten
überwachen und bei einem problem den
piloten becken sollte und weil dieses
system nicht funktionierte vertraten
alle ingenieure die auffassung dass das
flugzeug nach japan zurückkehren müsse
und reden hier ja ich höre gezogen wir
befinden uns im bisher kritischen moment
des fluges
die situation war so dass ein system war
teilweise ausgefallen
und dieses system war nötig dass der
pilot in einem bach überwachten umgebung
schlafen konnte und das war jetzt nicht
mehr erlaubt und dann war die
entscheidung die diskussion diskussion
am boden war daneben liegen wir weiter
und riskieren 1 piloten leben und das
ist ein sehr wichtiger faktor
oder nutzen wir die einfache chance wir
können noch umkehren fliegen wir zurück
nach nagoya
andré was meinst du ich habe immer
gesagt dass ich mich eigentlich sehr gut
fühle um weiter zu fliegen
hingegen brauche ich und brauchen wir
die unterstützung praktisch des gesamten
teams
das flugzeug befindet sich eindeutig
nicht im gewünschten technisch
einwandfreien zustand
deshalb sollten wir umdrehen um ein
flugzeug und einen piloten zu retten
solltet ihr beschließen weiter zu
fliegen so sichere ich euch meine volle
unterstützung als freund und projekt
support zu
[Musik]
aus meiner sicht als ingenieur ist die
lage klar wir sollten umkehren und die
probleme beheben
ich möchte eines klarstellen wir können
die hier unten am boden nur beschränkt
helfen wenn du dich dazu entschließt
weiterzumachen bist du da oben ganz auf
sich alleine gestellt
das musst du bei deiner entscheidung
berücksichtigt für andré und mich war
das überhaupt kein grund den flug
abzubrechen
für einige ingenieure hingegen schon
weil das flugzeug nicht zu 100%
betriebsfähig war und nicht alle systeme
funktionierten
innerhalb des teams wurde daher
verhandelt zwischen jenen die nach japan
zurückkehren wollten und andré und mir
und es war klar dass wir zurück in japan
wegen der regenzeit und so weiter nicht
erneut starten würden
das war ein psychodrama
wir haben so viele jahre an diesem
flugzeug gearbeitet versucht das beste
zu tun
und dann war ich am telefon und die
beiden manager haben gedrückt gedrückt
und gesagt wir entscheiden letztlich
also ihr seid nur beratend und das habe
ich schon zum teil einfach als ich kann
nicht verstehen dass andere ampere traum
als manager sich gegen das ganze team
stellen können sie zwingen uns etwas zu
unterstützen dass niemand machen möchte
das ist für mich eine große enttäuschung
das muss ich wirklich sagen wir hören
jetzt später erinnert euch an diesen
satz was immer in der zukunft passieren
mögen ich glaube das ist ein wichtiger
satz den ich soeben gesagt habe wenn du
den philosophen spiels peter dann spiele
ich den ingenieur vertraue ich glaube
wir müssen dieses gespräch nun beenden
ich hänge auf soll
[Musik]
so viele leute die die arbeit gemacht
haben um zwei als user entscheiden
nachher wir machen so oder so und es
kann dazu führen dass man einfach den
flieger zerstört das hab ich das war
emotional schwierig für mich als
ingenieure sind wir freunde von bertrand
und drehen in der nacht vor ihrem start
gehe ich in meinem kopf jeweils nochmal
die hälfte der stromkreise durch und
frage nicht habe ich wirklich nichts
vergessen werde ich nicht einen kumpel
töten auch wenn die piloten das sagen
sie übernehmen das risiko aber auch mein
eigenes leben ist anders wenn der pilot
stirbt ich werde das für den rest von
meinem leben mittragen
[Musik]
emotional wusste ich nicht ob ich meiner
familie gegenüber das recht hat er so zu
handeln
ob ich das recht hatte ihnen diesen
stress diese emotion um diese
schwierigkeiten aufzuerlegen
sie hatten die diskussionen ja auch
gehört ich wusste dass sie wussten dass
sich das flugzeug nicht in bestem
zustand da fand ich war mir sicher dass
sie äußerst besorgt sein würden hatte
ich das recht ihnen diesen stress
aufzuerlegen vor allem meiner frau
das hat mir extrem zu schaffen gemacht
so sehr dass ich einen fußballgroßen
klumpen im partner andré borschberg
entscheidet er überquert den punkt ab
dem es kein zurück mehr gibt entweder
wird es solar impuls über den pazifik
schaffen oder der pilot wird sich mit
dem schleudersitz retten müssen und der
flieger ist verloren
es gibt keinen quadratkilometer festland
zwischen hier und dort
das flugzeug steht über satellit in
ständigem kontakt mit dem sogenannten
kontrollzentrum in monte carlo
wir haben uns gesagt alle daten befinden
sich am boden war als der autopilot
nicht korrekt funktioniert hätte hätten
wir vom kontrollzentrum aus den piloten
wecken können
achtung etwas funktioniert nicht richtig
wach auf die große herausforderung war
dann was tun falls die verbindung zum
piloten abbricht
wir könnten ihn nicht wecken da hatten
die ingenieure wichtig eine absolut
geniale idee sollten wir den satelliten
verlieren ertönt im cockpit ein
akustisches signal um den piloten zu
wecken
er kann also schlafen um er kann mit dem
auto piloten fliegen
und falls plötzlich die verbindung mit
monte carlo abbricht wecken wir den
piloten durch ein akustisches signal im
flugzeug um ihm mitzuteilen dass er
keine verbindung mehr hat seine co
piloten am boden nicht mehr da sind er
aufwachen muss und sich nicht mehr auf
das system verlassen darf diese
möglichkeit war ursprünglich nicht
vorgesehen
folglich haben wir von monte carlo aus
über satellit im flugzeug ein neues
programm mit dieser pilot weckfunktion
für den fall eines satelliten verlust
installiert
ich hätte nie gedacht dass die gefühle
so verrückt und intensiv sein würden den
ganzen restlichen tag und während der
ganzen darauffolgenden nacht habe ich
meditiert man yoga gemacht
tief durchgeatmet um diese emotionen
über bord zu werfen und mich auf den
flug und die folgenden vier tage
konzentrieren zu können
die angst der angst bedingte stress sind
in solchen situationen potenziell sehr
stark nur dank der vorbereitung kann man
das verdrängen die größte angst ist
zweifellos dass das flugzeug während des
flugs auseinanderbricht und ich sofort
ab springen muss darauf habe ich mich
vorbereitet
das habe ich mit bertram geübt wie man
mit dem fallschirm abspringt wie man im
wasser landet wie man in einem ozean
überlebt
das training gibt einem einerseits die
gewissheit dass man das kann und
andererseits erlaubt es einem das risiko
geistig auszublenden damit dass eine
nicht stört ich würde sogar noch weiter
gehen und sagen dass wenn man
tatsächlich mit dem fallschirm
abspringen müsste dies ein so
außergewöhnliches erlebnis sein könnte
vor dem man sich nicht zu fürchten
braucht sondern es genießen müsste somit
habe ich mir gesagt sollte das passieren
genieße es du hast kein zweites mal die
gelegenheit haben mit dem fallschirm
über dem pazifik abzuspringen
wie nah sich borschberg an diesem
szenario befindet wird bei sonnenaufgang
klar
neben dem autopiloten sind die batterien
nicht mehr voll funktionsfähig
am nächsten morgen waren die batterien
noch zu ungefähr vier bis acht prozent
geladen
das reichte noch für eine knappe halbe
stunde bis 40 minuten flugzeit wenn die
sonne nicht scheint muss die
rettungsweste für einen absprung ins
wasser vorbereitet werden
allein im flieger auf sich gestellt
kaputte batterien kein autopilot
eine schwere belastung für borschberg
vor knapp drei jahren die erste nacht
habe ich praktisch nicht geschlafen als
die sonne aufging hatte ich den eindruck
als ob eine seite umgeblättert und ich
in eine andere welt eintreten würde
ich versetze mich vollständig in die
gegenwart sehr interessant war auch dass
die kleine kabine in der ich lebte mit
der zeit zu meinem zuhause wurde zu dem
ort an dem du schläfst ist sich erholt
arbeitet wo du einfach alles machst
deine natürlichen bedürfnisse sich
waschen und so weiter er schützt dich
es entwickelt sich eine sehr intensive
emotionale bindung die teammitglieder
hören über internet mit tag und nacht
ich erinnere mich ich war ganz allein im
hangar und hörte dieses geräusch es war
unsere idee atmete er war auf dem leid
der hunger weil ihr alle waren gegangen
es gab nur einen oder zwei computer und
ich führte andré armen alleine zwei oder
dreitausend meter über dem pazifik
ich war hier unten das war einzigartig
[Musik]
der computer lief in der küche die
lautstärke voll aufgedreht und wir
hörten ihn atmen mit der zeit erkannten
wir anhand seiner atmung durch die
sauerstoffmaske wann ist turbulenzen gab
oder eher ein wenig arbeitete es war für
uns sehr schwierig wenn wir ihn etwas
schwerer atmen hörten durch den ton
wurde das noch zusätzlich verstärkt dann
hat er uns jeweils leid wir wussten ja
dass er da oben ganz alleine war was
nicht immer leicht war wir hier unten
waren machtlos
wir hatten eine geheime telefonnummer
über die wir ihn anrufen konnten
er hat auch immer geantwortet das war
gut ruhigen selbst wenn wir ihn nicht
ständig anrufen
wir wollten ihn nicht stören
wir wussten dass wir ihn jederzeit
erreichen konnten
nach vier tagen 21 stunden und 52
minuten in ständiger anspannung die
lichter von honolulu schimmern in der
ferne
das ziel liegt nach 8000 279 km endlich
vor borschberg
ich habe die verbleibenden stunden
gezählt
nicht weil ich so schnell wie möglich
landen wollte ich hätte auch am vorabend
landen können sondern weil ich jeden
moment an bord dieses flugzeugs genießen
[Musik]
ich habe alle verfügbaren lichter des
flugzeugs eingeschaltet das ist toll
das flugzeug kann aus dem inneren heraus
beleuchtet werden wie eine chinesische
laterne
das flugzeug kann auf diese weise in
seiner ganzen breite beleuchtet werden
das ist sein markenzeichen
[Musik]
ich fühle mich keineswegs müde erschöpft
oder aber weiche knie sondern bin in der
stimmung eines erobern
[Musik]
bei der landung alle ok und erst drei
vier fünf minuten später ich war in
front ruhm vom mission control das sind
zwei geteilte räume und hinten sitzt das
planungsteam wir haben uns vorne schon
gefreut und dann habe ich mich herum
gedreht und habe das ganze team im back
room gesehen
gefeiert haben und dann habe ich um
geduld und sind wir die ganzen tränen in
die augen
das war schon sehr sehr emotional
der geniale dinge macht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir beweisen dass der ewige flug mit
sonnenenergie möglich ist das wenn man
nicht auf die landläufigen meinungen
hört sondern erfinderisch und mutig ist
das unmögliche dank einer fantastischen
team leistung möglich gemacht werden
[Musik]
ein meilenstein in der geschichte der
luftfahrt
doch noch ist die solar impuls nicht am
ende ihrer mission im frühling soll die
nächste etappe in angriff genommen
werden
das ziel die amerikanische westküste
[Musik]
doch mit dem neuen toyota rav 4 4 x 4
und hybrid die ideale kombination für
die schweiz
[Musik]